ces images de longues files d'attente
devant les stations essence on risque de
les voir encore quelques jours en
Bourgogne puisque notre région est la
plus touchée en France par les pénuries
de carburant 33% de ces stations essence
sans en difficulté d'approvisionnement
contre 20% en France en fait la
situation elle s'est aggravée le weekend
dernier il y a eu certes des
approvisionnements en Bourgogne dans les
stations essence mais les conducteurs se
sont rués à la pompe les conducteurs
vous envoyez là il y en a beaucoup qui
attendent patiemment d'avoir un petit
peu de carburant ça a donc créé de
nouvelles pénuries dans la région et
puis en plus le site qui approvisionne
la Bourgogne en essence c'est le site le
dépôt de Feyzin et celui-ci est l'un des
trois sites fermés en France à l'heure
actuelle alors pour retrouver une
situation normale en Bourgogne le
gouvernement à réquisitionné 10 salariés
ils ont relancé l'activité sur le site
de Feyzin conséquences dès mercredi les
deux dépôts de Dijon ont été
réapprovisionnés de quoi rassurer les
automobilistes avant le départ pour les
de la Toussaint mais attention un petit
peu de patience il faudra attendre deux
à trois jours pour pouvoir faire son
plein tout à fait normalement en
Bourgogne